making his first start of the season
made one last year in the regular season
against this houston astros ball club
through the ball
extremely well and as we mentioned
that new mentality that attack approach
let's hope to see a lot of that today
from the south paw shawn minaj
no different story in the very early
going
so far this year pinder's near the wall
pinder leaps up
makes the catch bangs against the wall
and that's how the ball game starts
pender is going to stay down and that's
a little scary
the a's are pretty banged up already
[Music]
is up but walking very carefully well
this ball just continues to carry we'll
talk about the velocity we've seen early
from mania but you can see pinder
tracking the ball checking the wall
and he goes up and makes hard contact
with his upper back
and then straight down on the backside
we've seen chad pinder flash the leather
a few times already in this early season
and kyle tucker will stand in
tucker two for 12 has driven in six runs
sacrifice fly and an rbi single in
yesterday's game
tucker gets into one towards right
center field this ball carrying and this
ball's gone
kyle tucker hits his first home run of
the year
the astros on the board early tucker
gives them a one-nothing lead they had
been making tucker reach
all series they tried to beat him inside
and he actually did a very good job of
keeping that front side closed like i
was talking about and staying
on that very quick to the inside corner
and then releasing through that and he's
got some of that you know he's got some
crazy leverage it kind of
i guess lanky pop because he's not he's
not slightly built
he's not over built he's built just
right for his swing
and it's jose or keady making his first
start of the year for the astros
arcadey five starts last season a 2.73
era and a 1-1 record
29 and two-thirds innings 22 hits eight
walks and seventeen strikeouts
for urquity here's canna against jose
rakiti drives one left center field
and off the top of the wall is gonna
have to hustle for second
the throw coming in is late and it's a
double
well that's what you like to see right
there
talk about the aggressiveness of sean
manaya on the mound also the
aggressiveness
of the lineup for the oakland a's been a
little stagnant for the past few days
mark cannon no waiting around here gets
a pitch up he can drive
gets it well hustling out of the box i
thought it might have had a chance
off the wall he knows he's got to pick
it up on into second rakiti turns deals
to matt in the dirt skips away from
castro cannas going to third here's the
throw the dive the tag
safe at third base aggressive base
running by canna
almost cost him but he gets to third
with nobody out and just ahead of the
tag of bregman
so lowry will try to get canned home
and that swing got ripped down the right
field line in the corner
fair extra basis scoring is kenna
lowry's around first going to second
with a double and these have tied it up
lowry and rbi double he's at second
mitch moreland the runner at first
against chapman curveball and that's
lifted to center
shallow racing out altuve it'll drop
between he and straw
altuve throws it back to the infield
quickly and the bases are loaded
for the a's and altuve is shaken up
he's lying on the ground on his stomach
through that ball he was in a rather
awkward position when he threw that ball
back in and now duvet on a knee as
the astros trainer will come out and
take a look dusty baker right behind him
i think altuve and straw collided and
now two vase to his feet and walking
around which is encouraging
and altuve walking back to his position
is going to stay in throughout walk to
straw castro batting in the count 2-0
this ball hit well to left-center field
going back on and looking up this was
gone
welcome back to the astros jason castro
opposite field home run and the astros
take a three to one lead
who is this guy castro the astro
so guriel this is sponsoring tough
runners in scoring position
uh first pitch swinging sends one to
right center field going back
on it is piscotty the center fielder
drops the balls off the wall that's in
play
that hit the wall even though he caught
it on the rebound jordan scores after
altuve a two rbi double for
yuli guriel as canna had the ball go out
of his glove
hit the wall and re-caught it i'm glad
you stayed on that because as soon as it
hits that wall it is in
live action and with two outs everybody
moving and
credit uh for getting a pitch early to
crush out to that gap
and just pops out of the glove of cannon
right there
game on let's go
strong runs throw to second base is a
good one and they got it
garcia throws out straw for the second
out a very nice throw
by hermes garcia that was fun to watch
sure was and a good job
by the bench bob looked like they had
wanted to pick off earlier in the
back not lucky with another foul ball
but this is about garcia coming up
gunning right now or kitty has allowed
just one base runner since the first
and that was chapman who walked leading
off in the fourth two and two is ready
he kicks he froze and that's a drive to
deep right center field
going back in the alley long run for
straw and it's off the
very corner of the wall at the 388 mark
ken
is around second he's going to third and
the throw is not in time
and mark kenneth has a trouble his
second extra base hit today
so he is at third with one out and
olson's coming up
hit hard now to be on the backhand long
throw and durian digs it out but it does
get a run home as canada comes in to
score
to make it 5-2 and give olson the rbi
and that'll bring up maya straw correa's
at first guerrillas over third
and straw grounds at left side deep in
the hole fielded by andrews goes to
second to get the out there
a run will score as guriel comes home
and the astros lead
is six to two and now two on one out
chase mccormick will hit against petite
and mccormick drives this one pretty
deep to left field
going back on it as tom looking up see
you later
first big league home run for chas
mccormick
it's a three-run shot and the astros go
up eight to
two on the first sunday of the season
ka'i tom
who this week has made his major league
debut in the outfield
will be pitching to the astros first
pitch in for strike so
high time is gonna pitch he's gonna get
an inning
of pitching before he gets his first
major league kid that's a proud mama
right there
he's going to get it out here looks like
and
he does so kai
tom pitches an inning gives up a hit no
runs
his era is 0.00
[Applause]
biscotti sends one to right field
and this game is over brandon belak
goes four and two-thirds perfect innings
the astros who started out 1968
1987 and 2001 4-0
all at home start out 4-0 for the first
time in the road
in team history and this series could
not have gone any better